hi I'm Ryan Wright today I'm gonna be
doing the longest reaction I have ever
done to anything before I go into this
I'm gonna give you guys a reason as to
why I'm doing this I recently posted a
video of Mortal Kombat X a 19-minute
video reaction of a bunch of fatalities
my girlfriend and I were in the video
right now my girlfriend is getting ready
to go to work so you might hear her
walking around and [__]
during this video I have seen like
almost every [__] video for Mortal
Kombat X now let me first tell you guys
that I already have really bad stomach
issues I've had to go to the doctor many
times for it I was even diagnosed with
irritable bowel syndrome and I do have a
vomiting issue you can ask my girlfriend
she knows I have a vomiting problem I
was watching this fatality video and I
had to leave the room for a second to
throw up real fast because I started
imagining it being real it wasn't the
game itself it was when I started really
picturing it being real then it started
getting me a little sick and I was
already feeling a little nauseous so I
wasn't expecting the video to pass a
hundred thousand views cuz it was so
long if I look a little tired here's why
I was like oh wow this video got a lot
of views you know what let's read all
the comments I know there have been some
trolls here and there but then out of
the close to 1000 comments I discovered
that five percent of them are that's one
of the best reactions ever ten percent
of it is that's not all the fatalities
and the other 85% was Ryan is a [__]
his girlfriend has more balls than him
apparently me throwing up because I
couldn't handle the imagery of it being
real I mean people think I'm a [__] so
today is part 1 of Ryan Wright proves
he's not a [__] I asked subscribers to
send in the most disturbing videos they
could find
I chose about six based off their titles
and the
- I'm gonna do today our Mortal Kombat X
all fatalities that's a 27 minute
[__] video of fatalities the other
one I missed was missing about 7 to 8
minutes of footage I obviously I'm not
gonna remember all these fatalities
there's gonna be some new ones and I
won't throw up but why stop there
people keep asking me to check out the
brutalities trailer as well which is
about 13 minutes so we're looking at
about a 40-minute reaction right now
stay with me on this journey you can
skip through it out of your [__] what
you do my point is I ain't gonna throw
up this time
I'm gonna handle this as well as other
videos to come all fatalities starting
now
time of Nana just another thing in my
way
[Music]
again if I'm gonna sit through this why
must we fight fate demands it
[Music]
nice beautiful part that [__] I will
attack you Jax
pin I'll knock you on your butt [__]
[Music]
I would never hurt a woman does that
would be the way to do it right mr.
Briggs
mrs. cage no paper tonight
nice and I hate I like it a lot we could
get back together you know once with
punishment enough fighting it is
[Music]
[Laughter]
it's not disgusting it's funny let's get
this over with what's your hurry do you
have to ask
[Music]
[Laughter]
singing wins
flawless victory fatality it's pretty
hot think your skills surpass mine I
know someday prove it
[Music]
kenchi wins
flawless victory feet it's not a
woodchipper would be the best way to
like murder a rapist or something you're
in my way let us see what you have
learned well then you know dad
[Music]
beloved sister you are a perversion I am
Empress of Outworld volatile you betray
me Liu Kang you misunderstand the price
of betrayal is death
[Music]
guitar women's flowers Victor smooth
very sings note
so zero prepare to rejoin your class and
the situation in Vegas
[Music]
Scooby wins
flawless victory pretty cool actually
speak of it Johansson receptions we will
see
[Music]
skip you wings flawless victory eat see
if you imagine this with real people
it's pretty disturbing murder i tire of
maintaining our innocence i
[Music]
some wins flawless victory fatality nice
sub-zero you will feel deaths cold hand
[Music]
sounds really just gets to you know big
Texas I meet my blood made you that says
all perhaps you a Sarah did more
[Music]
eight
goro you swore loyalty to my father once
gross but the sound effects mean it's
all good
greetings my son what are you doing here
when the student is ready the master
appears nice man
[Music]
yes there is no need to murder your
master like that papasan
I hear you've trained well allow me to
demonstrate that is the worst master
[Music]
mouth staff man let's go dad
breaking your old man's heart and maybe
your face
there's some legit fucked-up families in
this game wins flawless victory
[__] dad you just like your father
I'll take that as a compliment oh yeah
just to prove my point
[Music]
Kassie wings flawless victory feet
Salvatore it's just the game wouldn't
miss the father-daughter dance
we should called it another
[Music]
and I thought I had daddy issues huh
don't speak to me ever I just said your
dad's pain hi stop it
[Music]
come now you sure why would I not
flawless victory fatality the scholarly
earth realm Oh
knowledge is power not power enough
[Music]
your lesson begins i endeavor to learn
you will learn or die
[Music]
victory I'm a brassy talent
yo yo kill yo ah yes son almost that
show for the Elder Gods
to truck your insolence will be punished
[Laughter]
[Music]
scum baby that swings on me they're all
gonna be on you [__] dead
[Music]
[Applause]
flawless victory fades all the time he's
not disturbing at all it's really hot
actually you shouldn't have followed me
you should never run who's running this
day
[Music]
like your granddad off or something
let's get this over with
just like old times god I hope sorry
lady I don't remember that's seen before
that's pretty talked to me that would
mean you'd have to keep quiet you're
right
[Music]
we got seen Jack Nicholson's reaction to
the Juncker photo Kano lookin for some
action the kind that leaves you dead
[Music]
that would actually be a really cool
Western the crownless queen of fashion
100 volts you'll drop in one shot
[Music]
no victory for such a good rat your time
has passed
Rayden so you confront me Earthrealm
needs a new protector
[Music]
victory UK this time you shall die
finish now I see Goro kill someone
[Music]
- faith doubt identify yourself
destroyer of 10,000 Souls die boastful
one innocent
[Music]
I always thinking write down Simone and
Puma who can I see this on Goro
[Music]
King Kong wins
flawless victory fatality
your highness you are lower than the
jackal probably richer than in two
[Music]
victory fatality filthy traitor is beast
Farwest are out and your head
[Music]
I love it when the last person to say
something badass to taste the one who
usually dies but Shao Kahn's lackeys
must die I served you well you serve me
his lies
[Music]
come on man she's hurting and I need to
rip off her head
you offend me creature you're missing
out on some great cinema imagery baby
[Applause]
[Music]
artbeat analyst I'm not a [__]
yeah it's the Warriors wait you gave me
more water please
not this day Devorah babies fear
[Music]
beautiful oh it's almost over people
four more minutes
[Music]
[Applause]
one cheat my dark magics will overwhelm
you
lightning cuts through the dark finish
fear
[__] my ride flawless victory feet
Salvatore and the Christopher Lambert
little hope of victory
alright go around Richards earth rover
god damnit Goro you have mocked my
abilities I have indeed I will use them
to end you finish
[Music]
ever watch this with like no audio it
wouldn't be anywhere near as disturbing
master of souls master yours as well if
you teach me
[Music]
walking into mouth or winning into my
mouth go when in the end up slicing down
bodies for victory fatality
[Music]
all right go
finally oh no no you don't rip off the
Tipsy tank oh god I was gross but I can
handle visual holy [__] consoles not yet
[Music]
very sweet pretty sweet
boom 27 minutes and I'm still here on
this [__] couch guess what guys I
mean you don't need a guess I thought it
up at the beginning of the video but
that was just the fatalities I have not
seen the all brutalities trailer at all
I'm hoping this is the last Mortal
Kombat X video I watch but let's do the
brutalities peeps thank you my GN
[Music]
Oh
you know it
[Music]
hey babe
sure you don't want to get in on this
you sure who's a [__] now
[Music]
you're actually like
you enjoy that one you enjoy that one
[Music]
damn
every tally killed
they would work well in a world on
wheels
[Music]
kostik
really cool it a movie
[Music]
you shame little props my bleep
Thanks
[Music]
we eat
I like the brutality is more than the
fatality
[Music]
they're so cool actually yeah
except your death
[Music]
how unfortunate
public fortunate
[Music]
make noise ever
every day
[Music]
I like seeing your dismissed
feel the chill of despair
[Music]
you cannot win sub-zero wind feel the
chill of despair sub-zero had the best
one-liners
okay people 40 minutes of violence from
Mortal Kombat double the amount of time
from the other video and I'm still here
and I haven't even come close to
throwing up so [__] all you called me a
[__] if you're new to the channel you
can subscribe to the real rejects you
can follow us on Facebook Instagram and
Twitter
where I am trying to get product
placement by getting a lot of followers
I'm really hoping that a videogame
company as well you know provide me with
free video game systems and video games
you know like I know a lot of you guys
have to spend like hundreds and hundreds
of dollars or sometimes in thousands to
get the games and systems you want but
if I could get it for free with your
guys's help that would be so cool